hi everyone my name is Elizabeth and I
work on the trading floor but I'm still
pretty new to it I graduated from
college about a year and a half ago and
to be quite honest I'm still recovering
from the recruiting process I had to go
through to get here now I don't know
about you but this is the most
ridiculous thing that I still remember
about the whole process was asking
insecure college students what their
biggest passion was like do you expect
me to have an answer for that of course
I did and to be quite honest I really
showed those recruiters just how
passionate I was by telling them all
about my early interest in the global
economy which conveniently stemmed from
the conversations that I would overhear
my immigrant parents having about money
and the fluctuating value of the Mexican
peso they loved a good personal story
but you know what I lied and not because
the things I said weren't true I mean my
parents were talking about this stuff
but that's not really why I decided to
jump into finance I just really wanted
to pay my rent
and here's the thing the reality of
having to pay my rent and do real adult
things is something that we're rarely
willing to admit to employers to others
and even to ourselves I know I wasn't
about to tell my recruiters that I was
there for the money and that's because
for the most part we want to see
ourselves as idealists and as people who
do what they believe in and pursue the
things that they find the most exciting
but the reality is very few of us
actually have the privilege to do that
now I can't speak for everyone but this
is especially true for young immigrant
professionals like me and the reason
this is true has something to do with
the narratives that society has kept
hitting us with in the news in the
workplace and even by those annoyingly
self-critical voices in our heads
so what narratives am i referring to
well there's two that come to mind when
it comes to immigrants the first is the
idea of the immigrant worker you know
people that come to the US and searches
jobs as laborers or field workers
dishwashers you know things that we
might consider low-wage jobs but that
immigrants that's a good opportunity the
news nowadays has convoluted that whole
thing quite a bit you could say that
it's made America's relationship with
immigrants complicated and as immigrant
expert George for house would have put
it it's kind of like America wanted
workers but then they got confused when
we got people instead
I mean it's natural that people want to
strive to put a roof over their heads
and live a normal life right so for
obvious reasons this narrative has been
driving me a little bit crazy but it's
not the only one the other narrative
that I'm going to talk about is the idea
of the super immigrant in America we
love to idolize super immigrants as the
ideal symbols of American success
I grew up admiring super immigrants
because their existence fueled my dreams
and it gave me hope the problem with
this narrative is that it also seems to
cast a shadow on those that don't
succeed or that don't make it in that
way as less than and for years i got
caught up in the ways in which it seemed
to celebrate one type of immigrant while
villainizing the other i mean where my
parents as sacrifices not enough was the
fact that my dad came home from the
metal factory covered in corrosive dust
was that not super don't get me wrong
I've internalized both of these
narratives to some degree and in many
ways seeing my hero succeed it has
pushed me to do the same but both of
these narratives are flawed in the ways
in which they humanize people if they
don't fit within a certain mold or
succeed in a certain way and this really
affected my self-image because I started
to question these ideas for who my
parents were and who I was and I started
to wonder am i doing enough to protect
my family and my community from the end
justices that we felt every day so why
did I choose to sell out while watching
tragedies unfold right in front of me
now it took me a long time to come to
terms with my decisions and I really
have to thank the people running the
Hispanic scholarship fund or HSS for
validating this process early on and the
way that HSF an organization that
strives to help students achieve higher
education through mentorship and
scholarships the way that they help calm
my anxiety it was by telling me
something super familiar something that
you all probably have heard before in
the first few minutes after boarding a
flight in
case of an emergency put your oxygen
mask on first before helping those
around you
now I understand that this means
different things to different people but
for me it meant that immigrants couldn't
and would never be able to fit into any
one narrative because most of us are
actually just traveling along a spectrum
trying to survive and although there may
be people that are further along in life
with their oxygen masks on and secured
in place there are undoubtedly going to
be others that are still struggling to
put theirs on before they can even think
about helping those around them now this
lesson really hit home for me because my
parents well they wanted us to be able
to take advantage of opportunities in a
way that we wouldn't have been able to
do so anywhere else I mean we were in
America and so as a child this made me
have these crazy ambitious and elaborate
dreams for what my future could look
like but the ways in which the world
sees immigrants it affects more than
just the narratives in which they live
it also impacts the ways laws and
systems can affect communities families
and individuals I know this firsthand
because these laws and systems well they
broke up my family and they led my
parents to return to Mexico and at 15 my
eight-year-old brother and I we found
ourselves alone and without the guidance
that our parents had always provided us
with despite being American citizens we
both felt defeated
by what we had always known to be the
land of opportunity now in the weeks
that followed my parents has returned to
Mexico when it became clear that they
wouldn't be able to come back I had to
watch as my eight year old brother was
pulled out of school to be with his
family and during the same time I
wondered if going back would be
validating my parents of sacrifices and
so I somehow convinced my parents to let
me stay without being able to guarantee
them that I'd find somewhere to live or
that I'd be okay but to this day I will
never forget how hard it was having to
say goodbye and I will never forget how
hard it was watching my little brother
crumble
their arms as I wave goodbye from the
other side of steel grates now it would
be naive to credit grit as the sole
reason for why I've been able to take
advantage of so many opportunities since
that day I mean I was really lucky and I
want you to know that because
statistically speaking students that are
homeless or that have unstable living
conditions while they rarely complete
high school but I do think that it was
because my parents had the trust and
letting me go that I somehow found the
courage and strength to take on
opportunities even when I felt unsure or
unqualified now there's no denying that
there is a cost to living the American
Dream you do not have to be an immigrant
or the child of immigrants to know that
but I do know that now today I am living
something close to what my parents saw
is their American dream
because as soon as I graduated from
college I flew my younger brother to the
United States to live with me so that he
too could pursue his education still I
knew that it would be hard flying my
little brother back I knew that it would
be hard having to balance the demands
and professionalism required of an
entry-level job while being responsible
for a child with dreams and ambitions of
its own but you can imagine how fun it
is to be twenty four years old at the
peak of my youth living in New York with
an angsty teenage roommate who hates
doing the dishes the worst but when I
see my brother learning how to advocate
for himself and when I see him get
excited about his classes and school I
do not doubt anything because I know
that this bizarre beautiful and
privileged life that I now live is the
true reason for why I decided to pursue
a career that would help me and my
family find financial stability I did
not know it back then but during those
eight years that I lived without my
family I had my oxygen mask on and I
focused on survival and during those
same eight years I had to watch
helplessly the pain and hurt that it
caused my family to be apart what
airlines don't tell you is
that putting your oxygen mask on first
while seeing those around you struggle
it takes a lot of courage but being able
to have that self control is sometimes
the only way that we are able to help
those around us now I'm super lucky to
be in a place where I can be there for
my little brother so that he feels
confident and prepared to take on
whatever he chooses to do next but I
also know that because I am in this
position of privilege I also have the
responsibility to make sure that my
community finds spaces where they can
find guidance access and support I can't
claim to know where each and every one
of you are on your journey through life
but I do know that our world is one that
flourishes when different voices come
together my hope is that you will find
the courage to put your oxygen mask on
when you need to and that you will find
the strength to help those around you
when you can thank you
[Applause]
[Music]